et toi
je veux
[Musique]
ça me fait aucun doute maure en avait le
sens de la mélodie
michel fugain est dévasté par la
nouvelle de sa disparition ses débuts ça
me tue
[Musique]
on souvent
en audio comme en solo la voix de morale
ne laissait personne indifférent une
perte immense pour louise forestier
si comme père d'une petite serre alors
je perds quelque chose de super
[Musique]
au québec on l'a découverte en 1988 dans
starmania par la suite
maurane enchaîner deux succès à la radio
[Musique]
les variétés
pour résister à cette énergie totalement
communicative ça nous faisait danser
puis danser sur la chanson en français
quand ils pas forcément de la chanson
trop soft c'était plutôt art franchement
assez pour éviter par tous l'acceptent
passionnés et doté d'un bon sens de
l'humour
la chanteuse belge était une grande amie
du québec son duo avec céline dion en a
ému plus d'un
[Musique]
transféré à cheval
couvé tout chanter comme c'est sa vérité
son style naturel
son décès survient alors qu'il préparait
son grand retour sur scène
ici on la voit lors de son dernier
concert donné devant public
[Musique]
alors qu'en belgique on dépose des
fleurs sur les marches de sa demeure ses
amis lui disent un dernier au revoir les
enfants sont effondrés c'est un membre
de la famille oui absolument
donc ouais on a morflé
voilà morfler tout
ici wifi de queen radio canada montréal
[Musique]
ça